des bateaux amarrés au port depuis
plusieurs jours à saint jean de luz
comme sur toute la côte atlantique la
période est pourtant propice à la pêche
au thon à l'anchois ou aux merlus
environ dix mille tonnes de poissons
sont commercialisées chaque année à la
criée confinement oblige le marché est
fermé ce qui désole les armateurs
classique lassant permet pas tout le
monde de sortir sinon il y aurait
beaucoup trop d'apport de poissons et
les prix seraient catastrophiques avoir
du poisson est vendu donc pas la peine
de sortir non plus pour eux pour ne pas
voir certains ont fait le choix de
mettre leurs équipages au chômage
partiel
bon moi je préfère un petit peu
continuer là l'activité puis bon il ya
quand même une petite demande de
certains clients
le livre
de nouveau une reprise d'activité sur la
cliff saint-jean-de-luz
donc je pense qu'à ce moment là beaucoup
plus de bateaux pour en prendre la mer
et les pouvoir commencer un petit peu de
travail et on va dire normalement une
vente de poissons par internet a été
mise en place par la criée en attendant
sa réouverture le tourisme pâtit aussi
durement du confinement avec sa plage
ses restaurants ses rues étroites et ses
maisons aux volets colorés
saint-jean-de-luz accueille des
centaines de milliers de visiteurs
chaque année
en temps normal les jours de beau temps
la ville est remplie
les luziens en sont les premiers surpris
même en plein hiver des commerces sont
ouverts la ja pleurait mais ça fait un
peu ville morte carrément donc oui oui
c'est très bizarre comme sensation quand
on sort c'est très difficile pour chacun
d'entre eux
très très difficile tout est fermé aux
champs dans les rues le marché qui
viennent se faire mais je ne sais pas
comment on va tenir très longtemps cette
ville de la côte basque devra comme les
autres prendre son mal en patience avant
de voir affluer de nouveaux ces chalands
et c'est tout reste à